irma could become the first hurricane in
almost 60 years to travel the entire
length of Florida it could potentially
impact all of the states more than 20
million people part of Governor Rick
Scott joins us now from the Florida
Emergency Operations Center in
Tallahassee Tallahassee he just spoke to
President Trump a few minutes ago good
morning governor governor I want to good
morning Charlie a lot of people want to
help us say your prayers
I think the world and the nation
certainly got to pray for everybody in
our state we want to talk about the
status of Florida and Floridians but
first tell me what the president said to
you and what is he offering Florida I've
talked to the president pretty much
every day from the first call last
weekend he said I will provide whatever
resources you need they have done
everything I've asked for they've waived
rev regulations Dallas get fuel here
they've brought in emergency medical
teams he's got thousands of people ready
to help us respond help us recover and
so he said the same thing I said the
biggest thing you can do right now is
pray for us you know we always try to do
everything we can to get prepared
there's always more you can do I know
that a lot of people around the world
want to help you can go text at disaster
at 202 to two to make a $10 donation
we're gonna need more volunteers we've
had a lot of volunteers they will help
our shelters we have over 400 shelters
opened down we need nurses for our
special needs patients we have a lot of
special needs patients we didn't need
help distributing food and water so you
can go to volunteer Florida org but the
biggest thing right now is pray for us
it's hitting our it's hitting the keys
right now I talked to a friend down in
Key West of a little bit ago it's gonna
hit my hometown it's dead it's gonna
devastate my hometown 10 to 15 feet of
storm surge above ground
that's gonna be hard on I don't know how
anybody's gonna survive it's gonna go
all the way up to Fort Myers Sarasota
tampa st. pete and then we're to have
storm surge so i know my job and every
first responders job is to protect every
person that's in this state we're gonna
do everything we can to keep everybody
safe and alive
we have some questions for you governor
I know you just mentioned that 15 foot
storm surge in the Naples Fort Myers
area you just said it's hard to imagine
how anyone could survive tell me what
your fear is well my fear is that you
know people were complacent they waited
you know and didn't get out you've you
know and now it's tough to get it's
tough to get out there the winds have
already started last year we had
hurricane in the in the Panhandle and I
had the same issue just working working
work to get people out I had a lady I
talked to afterwards did she stayed in
her house because we're pets which we
all understand the water started coming
in he got the three feet she at a small
one-story house she walked outside
knowing she was gonna die and just thank
God for her it was a high water vehicle
that picked her up and took her to
safety so I just hope everybody you know
got to safety it's hard to respond right
now to because of the wind and the rain
but I know our first responders will get
back out there as soon as they can where
are we losing power
we're losing cell service I know a lot
of people worried about their loved ones
I know our first responders our
Emergency Management people will get out
to help rescue people as soon as they
possibly can governor you have certainly
been very vigilant and very present
during this whole process a very calming
force and I'm wondering if you feel that
the state has enough resources to help
the people that will need it here
you know everybody's we've done whatever
we can to be repaired of course there's
always something more you can do but
here's the problem the problem is this
is covering our entire state so
typically if it was gonna come in on one
Coast you could position assets people
food water on the other coast with this
coming straight up our state it makes it
more difficult we've pre-positioned food
and water
rescue a pair of people and things like
that but not as much as you could have
in the past so it might take longer to
get to people after that after the after
the storm passes so but I know president
Trump has committed to all the federal
resources I've committed all the state
resources we will not spare any expense
or resource to protect our citizens my
primary goal is to do everything I can
to keep everybody alive and safe well I
know that prayer is work and I heard you
issue the call for prayers you can
expect you've got a lot of people
praying for you all right now and you
said we're gonna get through this
neighbor helping neighbor that's right I
mean we're gonna take care of each other
this is a great state we have wonderful
people and we've been through storms
nothing like this in our lifetime
but I know everybody's gonna do
everything can to protect everybody else
governor Scott as always thank you for
joining us and keeping everyone informed
thank you